I was bullied as a kid and I was quite
unpopular in school and I was an only
child so I didn't really have many
people to back me up for a long time had
a chip on my shoulder about the kids
that mistreated me in school and then I
got toward maybe a few years ago and I
really really started to reflect on it
and realized that so many of the things
that I valued in myself were the light
side of something dark that had been
created during that time in school my
complete preparedness to just spend time
on my own means that I don't mind about
moving out to a country where I don't
know anybody and trying to make this
podcast thing work not having a super
tight social network as a kid meant that
I wasn't beholden to anybody when I grew
up other sides of it haven't been so
great because I still seek validation
because that was something that I was
missing realizing not only you probably
wouldn't be here if it wasn't for the
things that you went through there's
step one and then step two is and I'm
quite grateful for what I've done and
then step three would be something like
I'm proud of myself for having turned
something that was negative into
something that's positive but then
another level above that would be maybe
I should be thankful